okay so okay great thanks for having me
so my name is Tyler I'm the CEO of
clever and what I want to talk today is
about sales and I have a little bit of
insight into this I graduated college I
actually studied math and statistics
probably like some of you here in this
room and thought I was destined for this
world of Finance I was about to go start
at a hedge fund and at the last second a
friend of mine roped me into join his
startup and asked me to do sales there
which was something that I knew nothing
about and so had to figure out on the
fly and spent a couple of years there
figuring out sales for this very
early-stage company and then when it
came time to start clever you know we
started clever and I did it with two
co-founders who were very technical and
one very product oriented and we wanted
to build this product for schools and I
thought that experience would have no
relevancy whatsoever but it turns out
that some of the things that I picked up
at that this previous job whereas
figuring out sales have been huge parts
of what's made clever grow so quickly
today a quick background on clever we
build software for schools we are an app
platform used by developers and it's
used today by about one in five schools
in America and we started at about two
years ago and so sales have been a key
piece of that and I want to use this
time to just share some of the things
that have worked for me along the way of
course there's a million ways to do this
so you'll find what works for you so
first I want to start about how most of
how I used to perceive sales and a lot
of people see sales as having this you
know a lot of mystique around it you
know it's people who are you know really
articulate and impossibly charming and
they have these you know killer closing
lines that they use and I think this is
how I saw sales and I think this is how
a lot of founders I talk to see sales
because they say things to me like you
know we're just gonna work on the
product and build a great product and
then when it's finally finished we're
gonna hire the salespeople and what I've
learned is that hire the salespeople as
a founder the reality is that's you
and so you know Paul Graham likes to
talk about how there's two things you
should be doing at any point in time
when you're starting your company you're
either talking to your users or you're
building your product and not talking to
your users part that's selling and so
you know this is intimidating to some
people because they're like I've never
done sales and I don't wouldn't even
know where to begin but it turns out
that as a founder you have some unique
advantages that make it possible for you
to be really really good at sales and
one of those is your passion for the
product and what you're building and the
second is your industry knowledge of
what your of the industry and the
problem that you're solving and those
two things actually totally Trump sales
experience from what I've seen so this
is actually my co-founder doing sales
this is what sales looks like you know
and the very earliest days were startup
it's not Don Draper it's it's a lot of
calls like these but this is something
that even as a founders never done it
before it's very easy to do but you have
to commit yourself and what we did at
clever was we dedicated one founder
which was me to peel off and say okay
Tyler you got to go figure this out and
and work on this full-time because it's
so important to our business so a couple
things that I've picked up about sales
along the way and in trying to figure
this out you know the first thing that
everybody knows about sales is they say
okay it's a funnel and you have these
different stages of funnels and of the
funnel and you move your customers
through it um pretty common categories
there's this prospecting category we are
trying to figure out who's even
interested then you're having a lot of
conversations which is the second level
the funnel then you're finding out who's
really serious and you want to close
them and sign the deal and then of
course you're in the promised land of
revenue and what I thought would be
interesting would be to talk about each
each of this stage a couple strategies
that we've used a clever that have
worked really well so that these aren't
abstract things but things that you know
you can hopefully use it your startup so
prospecting so prospecting is the
process of figuring out who will even
take your call and you know one of the
things that I realized early on so
there's this guy Everett Rogers who
who's create
the technology of lifecycle adoption
curve and he describes it as a bell
curve where you've got you know your
innovators and who will try new things
and you've got your early adopters your
mid stage adopters your late adopters
your laggards and one of the things that
was really helpful for me in
understanding sales at an early startup
is he's quantified the tale of this bell
curve and this part over here the
innovators those are your potential
customers and it might seem discouraging
that only 2.5% of companies are your
potential customers or would even
consider buying from a start-up that has
no users and no revenue but actually I
found just the opposite I found it to be
extremely helpful to have this frame of
mind because you realize when only 2.5
percent of companies will even take your
call or consider using your product you
realize what a numbers game this becomes
so if you want to reach that 2.5 percent
and you want to get some early sales you
you if you're starting to do the math
you're hopefully starting to realize you
have to do a lot of calling you have to
do talk to a lot of people so early on
in the early days of clever this was my
job you know in the in the two months
the first two months of YC I reached out
to over 400 companies trying to get them
to take a call and and talk to us about
what we were building there's that
there's three ways that I have found
most successful in in in prospecting and
getting these people one is your
personal network that's obvious I'm not
gonna spend any time there another one
is conferences which is surprising to a
lot of people and then the one that
people are most familiar with is cold
email and when I say conferences this is
what people think they think I'm talking
about CES or you know III or something
and actually the kind of conferences
where sales happen look more like this
and we've got we would in the early days
would go to a lot of these because
you've got to go to where your users are
and if there's if you're selling to CIOs
and there happens to be a gathering of
them at a hotel and Milwaukee guess what
that's probably where you should be
so we go to conferences like these we'd
get the attendee list in advance we'd
email every single person in advance and
try and set up meetings so that when you
get there every single minute of that
trip was was well spent and this was
Hugh
in clever Shirley's day these this is
where we met all of our earliest
customers the second thing I mentioned
is cold email a lot of people don't know
how to write cold emails it's actually
really easy and the key is not to write
a lot should be really concise this is
an email template that I used early on
and you're welcome to copy it but it's
really short here's Who I am here's what
I'm building and I'd love to talk to you
about this could we find time tomorrow
it's really easy and and you can
customize this and find out for every
business you want to sell to who's the
right person to send it to and you can
send out quite a few of these so alright
that's prospecting and the reason this
is so important is because you've got to
build that first layer of the funnel
then you get them to take your call and
this is another place where a lot of
founders I think just have a lot of
questions about what to actually do and
the biggest thing to take away in fact
if you only take away one thing from
this presentation today the number one
thing you should remember is when you
get them on the phone remember to shut
up and that's really surprising to
people so many founders when I helped
them with their first sales pitch they
finally get somebody on the phone who
wants to talk to them about their
product and they're so proud of this
thing they've been building for the last
three months that all they want to do is
get on the phone and talk about every
feature and talk about all the different
things they can do and talk about why
it's the greatest thing in the world and
I have that temptation too it's just
part of being really proud of something
but it turns out that if you watch the
best sales people like the best sales
people in the world the top 1% and you
have a chance to listen in on a call
with some of those people like I have
the most surprising thing is how little
talking they do in fact I've seen calls
where the where the sales person told me
their goal was to only spend thirty
percent of the call talking and have
seventy percent of the call the other
person and they would ask a lot of
questions they'd say things like why did
you even agree to take my call today
this problem that we're talking about
solving for you how do you solve it
today
you know what would your ideal solution
look like and they're not they're not
doing the talking they're finding
they're doing everything they can to
find out what this person needs and hope
fully understand their problem even
better than they do that's what really
great sales is and in fact this is
something I drill into everybody at
clever it's a really important part of
sales and there's actually now if any of
you use uber conference they have this
amazing feature where when you hang up a
call it sends you an email automatically
and tells you how much you talked versus
how much the other person talked and
looking at one of those emails you know
if I'm doing sales that clever I get one
of those emails I can tell immediately
how likely the sale is based on how much
talking we were doing so you got all
these people now you got on the phone to
a lot of listening really understand
their problem and then the other part of
this stage that surprises a lot of
people is follow-up so here's a lot of
different steps that you can imagine
going through you know emailing somebody
not getting a response and emailing them
back calling them leaving a voicemail
having a pricing call you know there's
probably like you know 60 things up here
on this slide that could be steps for
closing a deal these actually aren't
just random things this is one deal that
this was the second deal clever ever
sign these are all the different steps
that we had it's in order to get this
done and you can see there's a lot of
really embarrassing things up there like
I emailed somebody and they didn't
respond and I email them again and they
didn't respond and then I emailed them
again and this is from somebody who
wanted to buy our product isn't that
crazy and that surprises a lot of people
I see so many founders who they have a
great call with someone they sent an
email they don't hear back and they say
oh that person might not be interested
well guess what this is what it looks
like in the best case and and so you
really have to have kind of this unhuman
unreasonable willingness to follow up
and drive things to closure now I'll
qualify it with that with one thing
which is to say when you're starting a
company your time is extremely valuable
because it's your only resource and you
couldn't possibly do this for every
single person who might buy your product
so your goal should be to get people to
a yes or no as quickly as you can where
you die is if you have a thousand maybes
and sometimes I talked to founders who
say oh yeah I have this great pipeline
of you know a hundred people who are who
have expressed interest in our product
and the maybes that work Illya if you
can get to a yes or no in some ways and
no is is even better than a maybe
because it allows you to move on and
focus on somebody who might be a yes so
have this superhuman level of follow-up
and ambition but make sure you're
focusing in on the right pieces all
right so you've talked to something
you've talked to a ton of people you've
had all these phone calls you followed
up with them ridiculously to the point
where they they just know you're not
going away and they've got to sign an
agreement this final step is something
that if you haven't done before might
seem opaque but it's actually really
simple it's called redlining so you'll
send over an agreement their lawyers
will mark it up your lawyers will mark
it up and you kind of go back and forth
if you're part of YC this is really easy
because YC has standard template
agreements that they give you so you
don't have to find these and you can
just you know use those but they've
never been available you know if you
weren't part of YC you kind of had to
figure this out on your own
one of the things that I'm really
excited about is as part of this
presentation
YC has agreed to open-source they are
deal documents so these documents that
YC founders used to get are now gonna be
available to everybody so this should
never hopefully never be a barrier to
anyone who wants to do sales for their
startup you've got some great documents
and then the other thing I'll say that
about this a place I see so many smart
smart people go wrong is you got to
remember what your goal is your goal is
to sign some deals and get some
reference customers and get some
validation and get some revenue that if
you don't do that your startup is is you
know toast so in light of that it's
really surprising how many smart people
will want to do 10 rounds of document
review quibbling over the most minor
points because of pride because of
intelligence whatever you know make sure
the agreement is the way you want it but
then sign it and move on I've seen
founders spend months quibbling over
some indemnification clauses and their
business would have been way better off
if they'd you know just sign the deal
and moved on to the next one so that's
one closing trap you can fall into I
have two more one other closing trap
that I see founders struggle with in a
la
is there talking to a company who says I
will use your product but I just need
one more feature you know or they say
you know I'd love to use your product
but it doesn't have this one feature so
we're just not ready and to most people
especially if you're ambitious when
somebody says that to you what you want
to hear is oh well I can build that
feature great
you know I'll build that feature and
then they're going to use my product but
the problem is it almost never works
that way in fact somebody telling you
that they would use your they want to
use your product but it's just missing
this one feature I would almost map that
to a pass in your mind because nine
times out of ten if you actually built
that feature you go back to them and
then there'd be one more feature or
there'd be some other reason that
they're not using the product so if
somebody says to you hey I want to but
you know there's this one thing that's
preventing us from using your product I
would do one of two things one say well
that's great let's sign an agreement and
we'll put in the agreement that we're
gonna build this feature in which case
you know you know that if you build it
you're off to the races or more commonly
what we did at clever was we would say
that's great we're gonna wait to see if
we hear that demand for more customers
and then once you have a lot of
customers requesting it then you should
build it regardless and then and then
you're not you don't have to worry about
doing something that's customer went off
which is what you really want to avoid
so don't fall into this trap it happens
all the time and the other trap I would
highly highly recommend you try to avoid
is the free trial trap because this
happens all the time people you know
they go down this path or the with a
customer it seems really exciting and
then the customer says oh well can I get
a free trial and you can't blame them
that's a totally reasonable thing to ask
for but the problem is when you're
starting a startup you need revenue you
need validation you need users you need
commitment and free trials get you none
of those things so you go you do all
this work and if you end up with a free
trial unfortunately you haven't made as
much progress as you it's actually
terrible you've you think you've made
progress but really at the end of the
free trial you're gonna have to sell
them all over again
so the way I handle this that has worked
really well is when somebody says can I
get a free trial you say well we don't
we don't do free trials but what we can
do is we're gonna we do annual agreement
here and what we'll do is for the first
30 or 60 days if for any reason you're
not happy you can opt out and that's a
way to get you the things that you need
while giving them the comfort that they
might need to take a chance on a startup
so that minor change is actually makes a
night-and-day difference when you're
when you're thinking about these things
all right so you've prospected you've
had a lot of conversations now you've
closed people you've gone through the
redline process you worked out the free
trials and you're on your way hopefully
to your first sales now early on you can
think of sales is just like any other
thing in a startup your goal is that you
don't have to do things at scale in fact
you can purposely do unscalable things
to try and get early customers that's
that's the fun of it but the other thing
that I think is really important to keep
in mind is once you've done this enough
what you should start thinking about is
well what aspects of this are repeatable
and and what aspects of this you know
are we gonna scale further and there's a
Kristof chance there's this really great
blog post online about the five ways to
build a hundred million dollar company
and he talks about he can have a
thousand customers buy a product that
cost a hundred thousand dollars or you
can have ten thousand customers buy a
product that cost ten thousand dollars
or you can have a hundred thousand
customers buy a product that costs a
thousand dollars and even though you
don't need to know on day one which
bucket you're gonna fall into most
companies do fall into one of these
buckets and so you should start thinking
about that as you're doing this if if
you want to be in the elephant category
of a hundred thousand dollar product
that's great and you're gonna have a
really high touch sales cycle and that's
fine you know that's sales force that's
work day that's great but if you think
you're gonna be a rabbit and sell
products for a thousand dollars a year
to businesses and your sales process
involves flying out to see them three
times and eight demos and and you know
three months of redlining then you
probably have to rethink something and
so I see a lot of startups most commonly
in that who want to be the rabbits and
sell for a low-priced product to
businesses not thinking about how to do
it in a scalable way and that's one area
where you can get underwater or it just
forces you to increase your prices so
this is how I think about different
businesses and it'll be helpful for you
so you get started and once you've done
enough for the sales to say okay you
know where am i and the corollary to
that is is how do I have to price my
product to be a viable business so that
is those are some of the things that I
figured out along the way building
building sales now at a few different
companies and specifically on this very
narrow stage of 0 to 1 million after you
get to 1 million don't find there's a
million blog posts you know about how to
get from 5 million to 50 million or 10
million to 100 million but this 0 to 1
step I wanted to did it focus the
presentation on that today because
there's not as much written about it and
it is something that I think is very
opaque to a lot of founders um I figured
this out just by doing it and I'm
confident that if you're starting a
company you can - if for whatever reason
you would like to do what I did and join
a startup that's figured it out and and
and hone your skills and hone your craft
we are hiring at clever so that's an
option but even if and if that doesn't
if you do want to start your own company
and you have questions about sales I put
my email address up here and feel free
to reach out anytime I'm happy to help
so thank you you know you it really is
basic blocking and tackling 1.1 or to
make before we get started as we
actually don't spend a lot of time at YC
focusing on this the main reason is the
best way you can make your pitch better
is to improve your company if you're if
you have traction and your product is
doing well these conversations are like
the investors want to see you succeed
and so if you remember anything it's
making a company better and the pitch
will be easier we're gonna spend the
time into three kind of sections before
the meeting what Michael will kind of
focus on will do a kind of a role-play
of what meetings actually looked like
and then we'll just wrap it up we are
going to do Q&A at the end we'll kind of
say five minutes so
there's something we don't cover please
write down your question that will go
through them nope without further ado
sue my name is Michael Seibel current YC
partner I've started two companies one
was called justin.tv
it ended up selling to Amazon the other
was called Socialcam which sold to
Autodesk and what I really wanted to do
was break down and demystifying the
process of creating a pitch so I think
what happens too often when I see
companies come to talk to me is that
they don't know how to simply explain
what they do and then ask for money and
that's basically what you have to do as
a founder so we're gonna go over four
things the first is what your 30-second
pitch is this you need to be armed with
constantly this is basically how you
talk about your company this is magic
whether you're talking to people who
want to give you money or don't want to
give you money you're talking to your
parents this is your go-to the second is
your two-minute pitch this is for people
who are more interested this is people
who you might want to raise money from
or people who you might want to get to
work for you or people you actually kind
of need to get a little bit deeper
notice that's where I stopped a lot of
people practice 10 30 minute pitches
hour pitches I think that's all garbage
I think you can get everything you need
done in two minutes and one thing I like
to tell founders is the more you talk
the more your opportunity to say
something that people don't like so just
talk less and it'll probably be better
so then I want to tell you about when to
fund raise because I think a lot of
companies get this a little bit wrong
and then quickly how to set up investor
meetings so 30-second pitch this is so
simple it's three sentences you can take
your time you can breathe when you do
this you don't have to get that much
information out the first is one
sentence on what does your company do
everyone I meet for the first time
screws this up you have to be able to do
it in a way that is simple and
straightforward that requires no pre
information on my part you have to
assume I know nothing literally nothing
about anything this is how you make it
super simple so you know usually what we
tell people is apply the mom test
if in one sentence you cannot tell your
mom what you do then rework the sentence
there is a one cent xx planation that's
your mom and your dad is gonna
understand so really really start there
and it's okay if we use really basic
language it's okay if you're saying hey
we're Airbnb and we allow you to rent
out the extra room in your house that's
simple right you don't have to say we're
Airbnb and we're a marketplace for space
I don't know what that is the yeah
that's gonna acquire more time so use
simple language very very important the
second is how big is your market it
makes sense to do a couple hours of
research figure out what general
industry your product is in figure out
how big it is investors like to hear
that you're in a multi-billion dollar
market it's pretty simple to do this you
know Airbnb might say how big is the
hotel market how big is the vacation
rental market how big is the online
hotel booking market these are simple
numbers to look up on Google and it
makes an investor understand
oh wait if we're big if we really blow
this company up it can be worth billions
of dollars don't skip this up second
sentence how big is your market third
sentence how much traction do you have
ideally this sentence is saying
something on the order of we launched in
January and we're growing 30% month over
a month we have this a number of sales
this amount of revenue this number of
users very simple if you can't speak to
traction in terms of pre-launch
you need to convince the investor that
you're moving extremely quickly so the
team started working in January by March
we launched a beta by April we launched
our product right convinced the
investors that you guys are moving fast
that this isn't some long slog that you
guys aren't thinking about this like a
big corporation you're thinking about it
like a startup where you can move fast
and make mistakes that's all you have to
do in 30 seconds three sentences from
that basis you should be able to start a
conversation about your company from
that basis I understand exactly what you
do you haven't understood you have no
idea how viable it is to be able to
explain to someone what you do in 30
seconds so really internalize that like
if you take nothing else away that's
going to help you okay 2 min
pitch now you've got someone you
actually have to convince of something
maybe even someone you have to ask for
money so I like to add four additional
components and these also go by very
quick the first is unique insight now if
you talk to VCS they'll say stuff like
what's your secret sauce what's your
competitive advantage what's unique
insight it's all the same thing
when I think about unique insight what I
think about is here's your opportunity
to tell me something that I don't know
here's your opportunity to tell me
something that the biggest players in
the market you're trying to enter don't
understand or don't do well this is the
aha moment and you better have it down
in two sentences the aha moment so you
got to crystallize all of the reasons
why you guys are gonna kill the
competitors or the really intelligent
thought that got this business started
in two sentences and I need to aha you
can see whether it's happening when
you're saying it that's why I like to
send this as so you get in and out fast
so if I look at you and I'm like uh-huh
then it's okay you you've nailed it if I
look at you and I'm like I already knew
that then you didn't nail it if I looked
at you and I just don't understand what
you're talking about you definitely
didn't nail it so practice that unique
insight in your two-minute pitch that's
all you're only going to get two
sentences to get that out there so it
can't be complicated and that's
basically the theme of this whole thing
right it cannot be complicated next how
do you make money you know your business
model I see so many founders run away
from this question because they think
things like if I say advertising people
gonna be like oh that's stupid
just say it don't run away if it's
advertising say advertising Facebook
some massive advertising business so is
Google if it's direct sales its direct
sales if it's you know a game and you're
selling in-app in a plaid UPS like
that's fine just say it don't run away
from this sentence it only has to be one
sentence long we're founders get tricked
on how will you make money is they say
well we're gonna run advertising maybe
some virtual goods we're gonna figure
out how to do this and maybe this and
maybe this well now you're saying
nothing now you've told me you have no
idea how you want to monetize
us this was a check mark that I just
wanted to write oh they know how they're
gonna monetize instead I'm writing a big
question mark so do the thing that
everyone else in industry does to
monetize 95% of the time say it and move
on like it's totally okay no one's gonna
hold your feet to the fire and say three
years later you didn't monetize this way
but it's much better to be clear and
concise than it is to start spouting out
every single way your company can make
money the next one is team I think that
this answer is actually really clear I
think you're trying to do two things if
your team has done something
particularly impressive you need to call
that out we were the founders of PayPal
probably want to say that we were the
founders an Amazon my probably wanna say
that so if you guys have done something
that has made investors money you want
to say that if not then please don't go
on about the awards your team is one or
the PhDs or the I don't care I don't
care what we want to hear is how many
founders hopefully between two and four
we want to hear is how many of them are
technical how many engineers versus
business people hopefully it's 50 50 or
more engineers we want to hear is that
how long have you guys known each other
we don't want to hear you guys met at a
founders dating event three days ago
uh-huh
ideally you've known each other either
personally professionally for at least
six months we want to hear is that
you're all working full time it's really
helpful we're all committed to this
business and what we want to hear is how
you met that's it you can get it out of
that two sentences very easy your only
way to build credentials is if you've
accomplished something and with an
investor typically it's if you've
accomplished something that's made
someone some money so don't try to
overinflate yourself if you don't have
that stat on your resume move on the
more you talk about a bad thing the
worse it looks so the last one is the
big ask when it comes to this and you
have to figure out whether this is a
conversation involves fundraising or not
what I tell people is like this is the
time where you kind of have to know what
you're talking about this is a time we
have to know are you raising on a
convertible
No are you raising on a safe you have to
know what the cap of that safe is you
have to know how much money you're
raising you have to know what the
minimum check size is these are things
where if you don't know these these
things investors gonna be like oh these
guys aren't serious or they haven't done
their homework so whereas in the rest of
this whole thing you shouldn't use any
jargon in this part you shouldn't just
be like oh we're just reason some money
like now it's time to actually use a
little bit of that jargon if you don't
know that jargon Google search it like
it's real simple you guys wander fast so
that's it by the way that's - that's all
your pitch done like game over
now you let them talk so when to
fundraise I think this is so important
right you've got this little growth
graph here investors like to invest
based on traction and so literally it's
always better to raise money when you've
got more traction than less often times
though you guys will be in the situation
where you're just starting or maybe
you've just launched so what you need to
do is you need to think about how do you
flip the equation your entire mindset
should be typically you are the ones
asking investors for money and therefore
they are strong in your weak how do you
create a scenario where you are strong
in their weak right that's where you
want to be fundraising so first how do
you know that you're strong if investors
are asking me to give you money you're
strong that might be a good time to
start fundraising if investors aren't
asking about giving you money are you
talking to people about your startup or
are you running super stealth if you're
talking to people about your startup in
your getting the word out either that
see the press or just through talking to
your friends or people you know doing
startups that's a good way to kind of
start feeding that the second thing is
have you created a plan so that you can
launch and grow without needing to raise
a bunch of money 95% of the startups
that I meet can get a product to market
with a very very little bit of money so
never put the investor in the ultimate
position of power we can't do anything
until you give us money you always want
to flip it around you always want it to
be this
move in we all left our jobs we're all
working full-time and it's moving if you
want to jump on great if not there are a
lot of angel investors that's the
attitude you want to have that's the
confidence you want to have if you need
money early always plan for needing less
money and always be able to show that
you've got a fully committed team that's
working fast that's going to be how you
gain an advantage when you can't show
traction if you can show that investor
that you haven't launched yet but you've
done eight months of work in one month
or two months that you've got a great
team that have all quit their jobs and
they're totally committed you get some
of that advantage back but you don't get
all of the advantage unless you're
launched and growing so something to
keep in mind finally how to set up
investor meetings this is really really
simple but I'm surprised at how many
companies don't get this right the first
is you want a warm introduction from
another entrepreneur preferably or a
previous investor of yours that's where
you want to start if it someone who's
passed on your company as an investor
offers you to make introductions that's
kryptonite don't touch that
so first warm introduction very simple
you don't want to cool call these people
you don't want to bum rush these people
the person the credibility of the person
is introducing you to investor is a big
part on whether the investor will take
that meeting ii think in parallel so
many people that I meet will run the
fundraising this super slow process we
met with one guy this week we're gonna
schedule a meeting with another guy next
week another guy three weeks from now
when you're fundraising you're on it's a
sprint it's not a marathon so you want
to schedule all of your meetings during
the same week it's extremely hard to do
but here's one trick that I love tell
when you're emailing investors you're
getting those warm intros the investors
email you back you say hey we left up a
meeting but we're building like crazy
for the next two weeks so can we set it
up in that third week right so then
you've emailed everyone that right so
everyone schedules that meeting three
weeks out it's better for them because
they're counters open it's better for
you because you've got all your meetings
in one week and also what did you do you
hinted hey I'm not desperate for the
money
we're building like alchemy you in three
weeks but we're building we're busy
like it's signaling all of the right
things so that's the best way to kind of
go about how you're gonna do that the
last thing is one team member should be
invested in fundraising full-time it
shouldn't be something that takes over
the whole company because it's very very
distracting so with that let's kick it
off to the next part of this hi so my
name is Dalton Caldwell I'm one of the
camera can get it okay yeah I'm one of
the partners of YC and one of the things
that we're gonna do today real quick is
a mock pitch and first of all I know
this is a bit contrived but this is in
this format of like a college class
where you do our best to have fun and
kind of demonstrate what it's like and I
realize there's a million reasons why
this why you could say oh this isn't
realistic of what pitch is really like
but um you know again there's a lot that
we can show you just in terms of my
background over my career I've raised
eighty five million over several
companies so I've set in a lot of
investor mediums and so I'm gonna be
pulling as many things as I can so again
we're just gonna try to show you
something to talk to and use it as a
learning session and your need you're
into a earlier caster right it's yeah I
mean I've done a couple startups yeah so
we're gonna do two pitches where we go
through them pretty fast as as Michael
said these tend to go fast so let's go
dive into the first one okay so so
Kassar I understand you you're coming to
pitch me dick and what can you tell me
about what you do so we're building a
communication platform that will allow
you know businesses and consumers to
collaborate on one single platform
rather than the kind of fracture state
that they're in right now you know I
don't follow
so like think about like what like
whatsapp or snapchat does for consumers
we want to do that for businesses and
and so what I have to do this in a
straight face
well what that uh what that means is we
want to enable consumers to talk to
businesses now that's really what we're
really the goal of our business our star
device I still don't
so who uses this part what is the part
of do so I mean it it it's for consumers
and businesses as a messaging product it
allows what humor so why would a
consumer want to use your product
because they want a message the business
okay well okay what can you tell me
about the the market or what the
opportunites the size of well I mean is
coming together a messaging companies
are very big obviously whatsapp sold for
like nineteen billion dollars and a
snapchat is like really growing very
quickly as well
so we I mean we think the opportunity is
very big okay so okay you tell me a
little bit about your traction your
numbers like how do you have you given
this to people yet yeah I mean we don't
want to kind of open the kimono and kind
of go into all the details here I kind
of had a high level we're live
we definitely have thousands of users in
the Bay Area hundreds of businesses you
know kind of can you tell me who some of
those businesses are there's ones that
you've been to we don't we don't really
want to get too much into the details
because you know we're still early we
don't want you know where we're trying
to stay style okay well can you tell me
about what you've learned so far what
insights that you've had from yeah the
consumers are sending messages these
businesses and we think that's great
so and these businesses are responding
to the messages and and we think that's
you know I don't think that's obvious
that that would happen so can you tell
me about what your business model is and
how yeah so we we charge businesses like
a monthly rate we haven't precisely
figured out what that is
we-we've right now we're both more for
free for the you know a few hundred
companies were in right now
but we're looking to probably do a
monthly how much do you think a business
would be willing to pay we think
certainly ten to fifteen thousand
dollars a month
okay so so anyway can you tell me a
little about your team and who you have
working on this
yeah there's we have five founders
technically I'm the only one who's
full-time right now the we're raising
money so we can get you know the rest of
the team on board yeah that's this our
can any of the founders program or yeah
yeah I mean we have I mean one of them
is a bio PhD but he's like he's really
picked up coding the I mean I'm I'm a
Python developer I did learn Python the
hard way oh look at the time well it's
been really great meeting you yeah
please keep me in the loop this sounds
fantastic I will just I will send you
updates and yell send you an update okay
that's all alright let's just go through
so let's obviously not strong so let's
just talk about some of the mistakes so
first of all you need to make sure the
purse you're talk to you knows what you
do this is seems really simple this
seems simple but it's not
so many times people get flustered they
get nervous and they start talking
really fast and there's no way you're
ever going to convince anyone of
anything if they don't know even what
your app actually is you have to know
your numbers obviously if you're very
vague or evasive like don't even have
the meeting if you don't feel
comfortable telling an investor what
your numbers are don't even meet with
them it means you're not ready yet
right for market size try to give some
plausible bottom-up analysis and don't
just name drop big companies that aren't
even really related to what you're doing
people tend to do that a lot
try to have insights try to convince me
that there's something that I don't
already know about the market that I
learn talking to you rather than just
what everyone knows about what the
market is right I learned nothing during
that particular pitch also the team just
like why are you working on this why are
you suited for it as good thing to do
and finally like he didn't drive the
conversation anywhere like obviously
that went poorly and he just let the
conversation just like flail around
until I cut the medium because we ran
out of time as fast as I could so anyway
that was that was not a good pitch so
let's try that again okay all right
let's do this okay
all right Castle well so I understand
you have a company and can you just tell
me a little
what you guys do yes so we're a
messaging a product we allow me that
sounds kind of vague so what we allowed
you do you to do is essentially message
a location so when you walk into a
cratenbarrel you can send the crate
Merrill manager a message like hey
there's puke in the hallway or if you're
the airport I'm trying to find this
specific day because I'm not at this
Airport where is you know where's the
terminal for version or forgot target
what aisle okay so is this a mobile app
or what yeah on the consumer side we
have iOS Android app but really getting
consumers to download apps is obviously
very difficult I don't I don't usually
just download yeah in cinemas most
businesses we have a call to action
which says text the owner directly we've
tested actually a bunch of copy that
works the best in small print we have
the messages are anonymous they also
lowers the barrier to entry I think the
most counterintuitive thing we've
learned in the kind of launch that we've
had work in 350 locations in the bay
we've been doing this for about three
months or about 11% weekly growth rate
in terms of acquiring businesses but the
most counterintuitive thing that we
learned because we weren't actually sure
as we'll people send messages yeah they
want to do people so and they do yeah
what's the number one type of message
that people so you would so originally
we started this product off thinking
this is going to be like in location
feedback that was the premise in
location feedback what we found is more
than half the messages are actually not
about feedback at all they ask things
like we were in this location in San
Jose this kebab stand father and son
it's just a takeout place and we saw
message that go through that went
through that said like are you hiring
and that's like very strange because you
would think like why would you just ask
that but we realized that we know this
is the owner and the person who's
walking in doesn't and so they they do
prefer to actually just text the owner
because anything that said that's an
easier so it's like a suggestion box or
it's like a weight is just like message
initially as who's not as the word was
and what we actually discovered his vast
majority the met I should say vast
majority over half the messages are
actually just things like when do you
open when you close because that's not
on Google do you thing are you catering
can you know do you have any
reservations available tonight okay okay
well in terms of your traction it sounds
like you said you had some businesses
like tell me about what you guys have
right now so we've 350 businesses all
from San Jose to San Francisco we sold
them ourselves as three founders we're
all technical but we actually did all
the sales because we learned a lot about
how these businesses work we actually
come from a retail background we
you built this product for large
enterprise players like Starbucks and
Walmart but we recognize that closing
those contracts and our limited amount
of runway wouldn't really be possible so
we wanted to get the product in the
hands of users so we did SMBs and that's
when we discovered a this like okay
messaging product it sounds like you
have some customers mean yes so we get
how could this be big though like okay
maybe you can get yes so in terms of
numbers of we we see one and a half
messages on average per location per day
that might not sound a lot but for a
business that's getting 30 messages well
you take like a yelp review or Google
review in a lifetime of visits they
might get five or seven and so they're
getting a huge volume of messages
relative to what they tend to experience
and they're private so they're not
public so in terms of how do we actually
make money it's not you know frankly
speaking we don't have a very clear
answer there the two paths are the SMB
side or the LCS and a large customer
side large customers we know from a
retail experience just regular feedback
tools are three to four million per year
so like a Sears where we came from SMBs
we've tested with are willing to pay $50
a month so I you know I certainly I
think this is this carrying large
business but and there's clear ways to
make money but I could I could see that
just a couple things like you tell me
about your distribution strategy and
also just a little bit about the team
yeah so distribution so the thing that
we learned in selling these SM B's is
it's really freaking hard there the
formula LTV - CPA lifetime value - cost
per acquisition and SMB is never going
to work out and so we have two solutions
one is to go up market like originally
planned Starbucks of Walmart's or two is
actually essentially pair with consumer
facing companies Yelp Google 50 min
talks about innovation yeah so we've
talked to Google and Facebook we're
meeting with the output we're basically
introduced every time you search for a
business there should be a message
button one of your consumers in the
habit of knowing they can send
essentially a text message to any
business that can help us get broad
distribution our real vision is to
become kind of that infrastructure that
messaging infrastructure between
consumers and businesses if that doesn't
work let's say Google Facebook and Yelp
don't want to give up that valuable
property it's really an ad unit we we do
want to just sell this as a feedback
tool to large large players all right
can you tell me what about the team
we're running on on yeah there's three
of us all technical we'd like
did a company before Sony's ax Google
engineer we come from retail so another
startup was a failure so I don't know if
that's good or bad but we've worked
together and yeah we're all technical
have built everything ourselves and we
sold everything ourselves
okay so we've already had a couple of
conversations with your firm we're
raising five hundred thousand and eight
point five million convertible note of
that 500 250 s committed by Mike maples
elide Gil and Aidan sync it and and Mike
with floodgate is willing to fill the
round we think you're you know you
particularly you and your firm can bring
a lot to the team with your retail
experience is this something that's
interesting to you yeah you know I think
this is really interesting I mean I
would need to talk to a couple of more
folks on my side but I do think this
this this could be pretty bad yes since
we've had a couple of conversations
before and and we're certainly willing
to meet again we are closing around this
Friday and so certainly take time and
let you know let your other partners
know I'll be available between now and
Friday I'll give you another call before
Friday for a close around but we'd love
to actually see you see in there oh okay
well sounds good I got to go but I think
thanks for great for that one thanks
okay all right very different class time
converse a so do you have a click yes so
in terms of that one you know some key
points here is try to actually tell a
narrative that makes sense to people you
notice there was narratives there I was
talking about people how they really use
it we were able to tie it down to the
real world which is good he was able to
demonstrate insights and actually tell
me something I didn't already know about
the market like there were there were
some some tidbits there it was more it
was more of a collaborative medium where
it felt more like a conversation than
just like a like I was interviewing him
about something in my opinion he
actually asked for money and this is the
other key thing is at the end you saw I
could have easily just been like okay I
gotta go but he he did talk about
fundraising as Michael mentioned and he
was able to provide all the context and
all the questions I would need to
actually have a serious conversation
with him if he was cagey about it or shy
about it and not clear on the numbers
that there's a very good chance that you
know I probably would just enter the
conversation
due to time pressure yeah it's
interesting you know we we've sent
another side a lot you really you can
tell when people are very passionate and
know their business very very well and
that's what you have to become okay so
closing thoughts here before we what you
want to do after the meeting before we
get into QA we're running a little short
on time after the meeting the first
thing just like the Tyler said in the
sales things follow-up this is this is
important and anything other than a
check or wired funds is a no so they say
we got to keep talking to partners I
assume that's a no and so you do want to
put some pressure the way that you can
do that is get deal heat ideal heat is
just a term which means there's a demand
for you to be in your round this is the
easiest way and an important way to
actually drive a price etc due diligence
on the investors so let's say you have
that five hundred thousand raise for
your seed round on the eight point five
million like we used this example do you
deal with some investors if you do find
that I do Dena diligent and Dalton and I
find hey he's actually not a great
investor I can get Ilan or Mike maples
or whoever to actually fill the rest of
the round it's surprising to us how many
entrepreneurs don't do this you would
it's like you would actually spend a lot
of time hiring somebody you're selling a
party a company somebody you should know
who you're selling it to to make sure
they you know they're the type of people
you think they are and then last no went
to stop so some founders get so good at
fundraising they just want to do it all
the time because it's much easier to do
then actually building the company I
think you keep fundraising does not
equal success and just because you
fundraise does not me and you succeeded
and nobody realizes that and I'm we say
this and we'll say this now but I'm sure
everyone will still equate fundraising
excess and read about someone's fun
reason and assume that means their
success but my guess is my intuition is
why this is the case is because a lot of
smart people their whole life they've
like applied to good schools and applied
to good jobs and they just think
fundraising is another like application
that they can just kind of check off and
building a company is much more
ambiguous but anyways that's that's the
session I don't know if we have time for
oh the end just under underlining that
build your company fundraising is not
the goal yeah we can do that
[Applause]
you